It looks like you're wearing a beautiful gown,
but you can be comfortable
because it's pants and it covers you like you're.
You don't feel exposed.
You don't feel like you're showing too much,
but you also don't feel like, frumpy, dumpy.
No, truly.
Because of the wide leg and the flowy fabric of this Halara jumpsuit,
it feels so elegant and glamorous,
but also like pajamas.
You also have deep pockets.
It has this waistband that helps create that waistline.
It's got the V neck to keep you looking slim up top.
I've worn this to, like, my kids little choir concert
and then I wear it to brunch.
I'll go on a date.
This would be perfect for a summer wedding.
Shut up. I am 5 9 and 165 pounds
and I got a size medium because I like the way it holds me in.
There's big time discounts for first time users of the TikTok Shop.
There is free shipping and free returns.
So click the link and give it a shot.